- [Moshe] Hey this
is Moshe Kasher.
- [Natasha] And Natasha Leggero.
- [Moshe] We just got
married six months ago.
- [Natasha] Which, we think
pretty much makes us qualified
to give love advice
to strangers.
- [Moshe] So,
that's what we did.
We packed up the car, hit
the road and spread the love.
- [Natasha And Moshe] This
is The Honeymoon Tour.
(light upbeat music)
- Is there something that
you would like to discuss
with the group that
you would like to maybe
address in your
relationship with Josh?
- Butt stuff.
(audience laughs)
- You want it, or he wants it?
- Umm.
- I mean, if you want it,
he will be the luckiest man
in the world because
I've never heard of that.
- I wanna give it.
- You wanna give--
- You wanna give it?
Oh, okay, that's so weird that--
- [Natasha] Josh,
you're so lucky!
- That's so weird that Josh
didn't want to come up.
How weird, so weird.
He's like, "I know exactly
what you're gonna bring up,
"you're going to bring up
the fucking thing again.
"I'm not getting pegged,
"I'm not interested
in getting pegged,
"if you want that you find
another guy, I've told you
"many, many times I'm
not interested in that."
- Aww, that's so cool
that she wants to do that.
Wait--
- I don't think it's cool.
(audience laughs)
No, are you into it?
- No.
- Well he's not into it.
- Wait, but hold on, what
sparked your interest
in the inspiration cause
this is clearly something
you've brought up with
him more than once?
- I don't know, why not?
- Well, I would say your
partner not consenting
is a good reason.
- You know what today is?
- Uh, hump day?
(laughter)
Why do people still say that?
- It's our eight
month anniversary.
- Hump day!
- No, today--
- No, that's hump day.
- No, it's hump night cause
it's our eight month
anniversary, we need to hump.
(laughs)
- Okay, that's cool,
our wedding was fun.
- It was the best.
It was the first non-boring
wedding I've been to.
Except for the wedding of
all of my friends and family.
- Wish we could do it again.
- We can do it again, we're
going to Las Vegas tomorrow.
We could straight up
do a wedding there.
- You wanna renew our vows?
- I guess we would have
to renew our vows, yeah.
- Would you really do that?
- Why not, I think
that'd be fun.
We renew our vows and we can
go out on the town in Vegas!
- [Natasha And Moshe] Baby!
- [Natasha And
Moshe] Vegas, baby!
- And then be like
schwing, you know?
- What is it about it?
Is it, what is it?
Is it the psychological dynamic?
Is it, what's the--
- Something about
getting there, just--
- It feels dominating from a
woman and that, maybe it's an
ignorant part of my like little
like pathetic male brain,
but I don't like the
psychological dynamics of it.
It feels like--
- I'm getting emasculated.
- I'm getting bent
over and fucked.
- You know what I'm saying?
I just, there's
a thin, but I'm--
- That's for women.
(audience laughs)
Yeah you little bitch!
You deserve that
you little bitch!
(audience laughs)
- Oh man, I haven't
thought about
our wedding night
in a long time.
(audience laughs)
- Alright, let's go
renew our vows then.
- You sure you want
to renew your vows
with someday that
goes "schwing"?
- Well, we never even had
vows so there's low risk.
- Oh, so who should we
have do the ceremony?
- Oh like a Liberace
impersonator?
- That's funny, I bet
a Liberace impersonator
hasn't gotten a
call in a long time.
- What about uh--
- What about Elvis?
No that seems cliche.
- What about Carrot
Top impersonator?
- A Carrot Top impersonator?
Why not just Carrot Top?
- I mean, that's a good point.
- So what if she just, what
if he just lets her do it once
and then if he doesn't like it
they never talk about it again.
Would you be happy
with that Christine?
- Yeah, that's fine.
- That's cool. What if he
was into say, like, um--
- I don't wanna fuck him
I just wanna finger him.
- Oh, all you want to do
is put a finger in there?
Josh, man up dude.
(audience laughs)
I mean, come on.
- First of all you
should clip your nails.
I mean, that's like
the number one thing.
I wouldn't want that up my ass.
Those are long!
How about she cuts her
nails, he lets her do it once
all the way, and then
never talk about it again
if you don't like it.
- What do you mean all the way?
All the elbow.
What's a thing that you
want in the relationship
that you wish was different.
- I don't know.
- Nothing she does bothers you?
Except for try to sexually
assault you every single night?
- No, we've got an agreement.
Keep the Kardashians out of
the house and we're good.
- Oh so she can't watch
reality TV type of stuff?
So if she's giving you
that, give her one pinky.
Okay, how about one knuckle?
Yeah, he says I'm right.
Alright, well we just,
I don't know if I feel
good about this, but we--
- Pinky tonight!
- Room 207!
- [Moshe] Give it up for them!
- We'll see you there.
That was good.
- That was really good.
- That was a great show tonight.
- Oh, the show, yeah
that was good too.
- Yeah, no I feel like we really
help people with
the love advice.
- For sure, especially
that one couple.
- Oh, the butt couple?
- Yeah I really feel
like we opened them up.
- I agree.
Alright, goodnight.
- Goodnight babe.
- [Natasha and Moshe] Goodnight!
- [Christina And
Josh] Goodnight!